نبدا من السعوديه ومن الشعر وما اجمل
الشعر فبعد عام القهوه العام الحالي عشرين
22 العام 20 23 اختارته المملكه عاما
للشاعر العربي لماذا هذا الخيار السبب هو
تعميق الاعتزاز بالتراث وتوصيل لدوره
الشعر في هويه الجزيره العربيه وحضارتها
مبادره عام الشعر العربي ستكون مظله جامعه
لمجموعه من المبادرات على امتداد السنه
وبحسب البيانات الرسميه ستعمل وزاره
الثقافه السعوديه من خلال عام الشعر
العربي على دعم الحاله الشعريه العربيه
على كل حال بين وسط السعوديه وشمالها
وجنوبها بين نجدها وحجازها عاش كبار شعراء
العرب سنعود مع عبد الرحمن العصيمي الى
رحله الشعر من السعوديه والى العالم
[موسيقى]
من العاصمه السعوديه الرياض وقبل الاف
السنين نثر العرب شعرهم معلقات جزاء
[موسيقى]
امرؤ القيس الذي قال قفا نبكي من ذكرى
حبيب ومنزلي بسقط اللواء بين الدخول
عنتره ابن شداد الذي صدح يوما قائلا واختر
لنفسك منزلا تعلو به او متكريما تحت ظل
القسطلي هذه الابيات وغيرها ما زالت الى
اليوم شاهده على لغه الضاد وعظمتها تحكي
قصص العرب وايامهم وتنقلوا الى الاجيال
اللاحقه سيره اقوام مروا من هنا هذه الارض
التي تحتفي بالشعر العربي وتسمى عام
عاما له
[موسيقى]
هنا من هذه الارض كان العرب يحتفون بلغتهم
وعلى امتداد تاريخهم كان الشعر العربي
المنطلق من الجزيره العربيه
الاكثر تاثيرا في تاريخ العرب الثقافي
والاكثر انتاجا لهذه الروائع الادبيه التي
ما زالت راسخه في الحضاره الانسانيه
[موسيقى]
اليوم ما زالت السعوديه تحتفي بالشعر بدعم
كبير ورعايه لا مثيل لها من العاهل
السعوديه الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز وولي
عهده الامير محمد بن سلمان دعم زاد من
مكانه الثقافه السعوديه عربيا ومنحها
القدره على الاعتزاز والاحتفاء بجذورها
الراسخه لتكون جزءا من تحقيق مستدفات رؤيه
2030 في ابراز الهويه الوطنيه والثقافيه
لصباح العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي الرياض
على كل ينضم الينا من جازان الشاعر يحيى
رياني اهلا بك سيدي يحيى معنا في صباح
العربيه اذا السعوديه تحتفي بالشعر العربي
تسمى عام 2023 عاما له لو نتحدث اولا عن
القيمه المحوريه للشاعرنا وتاثيره في ثقه
ثقافه العربيه
اهلا وسهلا وصباحكم صباحكم شعر
هذا العام او هذا
المبادره وهذا الاحتفاء بهذا العام العام
2023 ليكون عامل للشعر العربي هو اكبر
تاكيد على امتداد حضارتنا وتاريخنا
وهويتنا المرتبطه والضاربه في اعماق
التاريخ بالشعر العربي الشعر الذي الذي
ابتدا في في حقب قديما يعبر الانسان عما
في داخله ابتداء به
كيف نبكي من ذكرى حبيب ومنزلي الى حبي
بصحن كيف اصبحينا الى الغادر الشعراء
ترنمي ومثيلاتهم القصائد الخالده في جبين
الدهر يؤكد حرص القياده واهتمامها
بهذا الارث العظيم والموروث الكبير الذي
تضمه هذه الارض المباركه ومنها نشات
القصائد التي لا تزال
الشعر كلام عميق وكاتبه اعمق لكن هل مازال
للشعر العربي حيزا كبيرا وتقديرا للشعراء
في يومنا وعالمنا هذا
هو هي مساله جدليه هل لا زال الشعر حضور
وهل لا زال الشاعر تقدير تكلم عن الشعر
الفصيح لا شك انه مرض بمراحل متذبذبه في
الماضي وفي الحاضر يعني
يتعرض للعوامل كثيره ربما هي من اهمها ما
يتحدث عنه الاعلام وما يتحدث به الاعلام
لكن انا اتصور انها فتره ركود مرت وعدت
ولكن الان معامل الشعر العربي سيكون حضور
وتوهج كبير لا شك سيكون الشعر وللشاعر نظر
الاهتمام القياده بهذه بهذه اللغه العظيمه
وبهذا بهذا الشعر الذي الذي هو ديوان
العرب كما قال الذي يسجل تاريخه وماثره
وذكرياتهم وانتصاراتهم واسمائهم والهجاتهم
ولغاتهم فهو هو ديوان العرب كما قالوا
ونحن نتفائل بهذا العام بانه كما مر في في
فتره الماضيه اقول ركود ربما للشاعر
العربي ولحضوره على الاقل في في في في
مجال صغير النخبه لكن مع عام الشعر العربي
انا متفائل شخصيا انه
على الساحه حتى الرسميه طيب اهميه هكذا
مباراه سيتي يحيى لدعم الحاله الشعريه
العربيه وتعزيز حضورها في المجت بين
الشباب اليوم
التواصل الاجتماعي في وجهه نظري
او البنات هذا يغني وهذا ينشد وهذا يقول
شعرا حتى لو لم يكن يعني يجيده خليني اقول
القاء ابوه او يجيد
نحو لكنه يحبه كثيرا ويطلب لسمعه وانا
سعيد جدا مجموعه من الاعمال الفنيه سواء
غنائيه سواء شاديه سواء القاء بدات في
الامر الاخيره ساهمت وسالته الاجتماعي في
تعزيزها بين الشباب حتى لو كانت محاولات
بسيطه وخجوله الا انها تؤكد ان الشاب
الشباب متلهف ومقبل على على ان يتبنى هذه
اللغه وهذه اللغه الشعريه عندما نتابع
مراحل تطور الشعر وخصوصا انه جاء من
الجزيره العربيه والشعراء القدامى اليوم
يعني كنا نتحدث عن كلمات ومصطلحات ثقيله
وصعبه جدا هل اليوم الاتجاه الشعري الى
التحدث بالعاميه ومحبب اكثر لقلوب الناس
منه الى الف
ساقول كلام قد يغضب او قد يزعج بعض
الزملائك من الشعراء انه المرحله الحاليه
تحتاج من فعلا اللغه العربيه لغه ثريه
وهناك صعبه لكن المفترض على شعراء الجيل
وشعراء نخاطبون الشباب نخاطبون الناس عامه
الناس ان ينزلوا بالفاظهم وان يختاروا من
اللغه العربيه
الانسب الالفاظ هناك في اللغه العربيه في
العين الف معنا وفي الاسد مئه معنا فلاذا
نختار الكلمات الصعبه وهناك متنفس كبير في
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ان تقدم القالب
الشعري بابسط طريقه واسهل لفظ واسهل معنا
ليصل الى قلوب الناس متى ما تبنى الشعراء
هذا المنهج وان اللغه العربيه لغه واسعه
وبامكانك ان تبسط الناس لا تنفرهم من
اللغه العربيه ومن الشعر العربي باختيار
ابسط افضل الالفاظ حين سنقول ان الشعر
العربي الفصيح قد وصل الى قلوب الشباب طيب
لو نسمع منك شيء شاعر يحيى اقول بما اننا
نحن
الشعر العربي ومن هذه الارض التي امتد
منها المعلقات وتبدا منها الشعر اقول انا
السعوديه ذا اصلي وادي بلد وصيه لابي اوصي
بها ولدي هذا جواز الذي في العمر احمله من
الوفاء كحمل الروح في جسدي النوق والخيل
مركوب ويجمل بي السيف والخنجر الزاهي على
عضو
انا السعودي كل الناس تعرفني في لهجتي
ولباسي او بجود يدي انا السعودي والتاريخ
يشهد لي شيدت مجدا بغير العزم لم يشهد
الاربعون سروه والخيل مضمره مع الامام على
نور من الرشد تقدموا وظلام الليل محتلق
واذن الفجر والاعداء في بددي الملك لله ثم
الملك سار به عبد العزيز الوهادي وثمه
الاسد انا السعودي راياتي وما نكست او
استباح احتلال الخبره في بلدي اذا رضيت
نخيل الجود مثمره وان غضبت فلا ابقي على
احد انا السعودي داري سوف احرسها ولا اخاف
سواه الواحد الاحد
يسلم هالتم ويسلم هالكلمات الصادقه شكرا
لك من جزان الشاعر يحيى ريحاني شكرا لك
وفي نهايه الفقره وكما في سؤالنا التفاعلي
سالنا الناس في السعوديه ماذا تحفظون من
ابيات الشعر
امانه الحب وعشاقا وحبك انت احياني ولو
خيرت في وطني لا قلتها واقطعني ولو انساك
يا عمري حنايا القلب تنساني
ففي عينيك عنوانك هذه اول ابيض شعر انا
حفظتها في حياتي وبمناسبه انه هذا العام
هو عام الشعر خلينا نشوف الناس ايش حافظه
من ابيات الشعر
للامانه اول شيء خطر على بالي الان
قم للمعلم وفيه التبجيله كاد المعلم ان
يكون رسولا للمتنبي الخيل والليل والبيداء
تعرفني والسيف والرمح والقرطاس والقلم
تفعل ما تشاء وطب نفسا اذا حكم القضاء
كشعر او عام الشعر عربي يستحضر فيه طبعا
كبار الشعراء خصوصا في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
رمز الشعر الامير بدر بن محسن الامير عبد
الرحمن المساعد لم يدخل للفيصل الامير عبد
الله الفيصل
احد رواد الشعر العربي طبعا
ما عاد بدري تدري العمر مره سرقه سنينه من
الاحظات قولي احبك كي تزيد وسامتي فبغير
حبك لا اكون جميله
[موسيقى]